é o lado diz pessoal de quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo
jamais um vídeo e os estragos e que
aproveite nal dentão impõem porque os
então ao pará barrigas portamento ao
professor e nos dentes
cuidado não tento fazer isso em casa o
meu deus criou prudente em casa o bayern
vem mais por aí com um tubo enquanto
estava jogando beisebol 20ª do la na
boca e quebrou um país grande o seu
lento e incisivo inferior em vez disso o
material dentário restante deverá ser
extraído e um dentro difícil será
implantado aqui vamos manter um dente
plástico pra mim ficar bonito
pego posicionador nós não vamos usar um
bisturi 90 até agora vamos ter aqui
exatamente um trabalho agora próximo
cilindro do raio x do eliseu e por que o
michael jackson nunca manda fazer essas
coisas a tentar aqui ok raios x um botão
prefeito o salvador do dente quebrado
parece estar em bom estado podemos
começar a oposição tenta assim para 30
se jogar na bola meu ainda são que está
uma escada ovação com uma pedra ao bater
se com o vento teve um bairro para que
james não sinta dor vamos injetar um ano
esteve no local no local da cirurgia
primeiro vamos aplicar 10 anos tese qo
antístenes tese é uma equipe que quer
levar craques da selecção menos dolorosa
eu não consigo na paixão a mulher pegou
uma diferença imensa expressa um
cotonete mas não é já um está um
componente legal o que nós estamos
usando um cotonete onde há um fluxo
rural nós vimos presos eram os melhores
com distintos não eu sei que está em
brasília era ok ok e pronto vamos
acalmar as piadas marques porque as
pessoas estão fartas piadas de boston
até agora aplicou gelo no local da
injeção lugares né pois é agora que vou
começar a estrutura metas interrupção é
só uma injeção bom trabalho
james não sentir nenhuma dor nessa área
durante algumas horas
ok eu espero que isso não durou horas
não é porque tem que fazer o melhor até
agora vamos usar o valor dental milva
dor e o valor dental para afrouxar efron
charlie
puxar a inovar o dente a partir de um
favor e pronto é o que vamos afrouxar o
dente eles é que estão aí mas hoje foi
bosta
vamos fazer agora estou vendo que o
rapaz é tão não uso o valor para
afrouxar afro mil esta palavra é fruto
charme eu agora só prepare se estão a
comer alguma coisa para já o vídeo como
e depois paixão mas peguei um caminho
para fazerem estão primeiros não jogá lo
é este aqui é frustrar o vento que sopra
cima bom trabalho agora podemos removê
lo dentro usando o far ceps o far cry
streisand são grandemente está agora
vamos arrancar o dente meu isto e isto
isto é um homem capaz não é forçar os
números tenham obrigado jesus morte
primeiro vamos afrouxar mais prudente
antes movê lo
eu nem queria fechar mais justo porque
queria quebrar isto lá funciona mais
frouxos tudo ok agora porque só por cima
do meu o gigante por mais um trabalho
agora vamos usar um instrumento de
sucção cirurgia para aspirar o sangue
era um lixo para contorná-lo ótimo de
hora vamos enxaguar a boca de james com
água para levar qualquer resíduo sangue
o material ou se útil até lá aí
exatamente o toque vai morrer afogada
parece que é um pouco de tecido da
gengiva no caminho pegou o bisturi na
mesa vamos usar o bisturi que eu vou
fazer é me conquistou e meu pai que era
um livro histórico e faça uma incisão no
tecido e gengiva para podermos abri la
aquilo é bush que uma infecção
chupeta agora podemos fazer um furo no
osso da mandíbula do jaime muraro ruas
agora né
eu estou a tratar o vento gás consulta
uma prévia vamos usar outra troca para
alargar o furo pega broca foi escrita um
ritmo que interessa aqui e lá
o evento dura mais nós temos que acabar
em um minuto e 30km chave da cantora
quando ela está chata é que é isto aí
tem que fazer de um sonho daí temos para
fazer coisas que você fica ai hospital
estão fundo meu caso agora vamos namorar
o rapaz é exatamente agora tirar do foco
a nós vamos fazer um novo pegos por
tecnológicos por tecnológico importante
é isto é claro não vão ter um fim quem
vem assistir isso é preciso uma
trabalhando caraças flash o injetor
contenda gengibre oficial na mesa
oficial dos indignados é isto mesmo sem
maionese e isso agora mede por cima e
vamos poder 10 segundos mas foi também
foi na ok vamos colocar em que o
primeiro tempo novo motor e painel vai
perder e já teve problemas na cirurgia
cirurgia não teve um bom resultado e se
o paciente agora está muito instável
chegou a hora de colocar a prótese
definitiva na boca do james pega prótese
definitiva na mesa emitir esta esta será
nossa espera eu não quero completá
poderão dentro
agora podemos usar as 4 no próximo verão
o chefe de cimento e manter o cimento
escolha a espátula esta fechar ok tava
em um trabalho excelente agora vamos
faturar suturar e gengiva o que é uma
estrutura meu é isto aí cruzeiro é
cozinheira satisfatoriamente implantar
um trabalho de 50
a segunda tentativa mas foi obrigada a
doutora estou muito bem agora são gêmeos
com dentro 1 a 1 então é isso ai espero
que vocês tenham gostado a próxima
cirurgia vai ser do aprendiz está bom e
já sabem que quiserem ver mais deixa o
nosso apoio lá e comentário favorito
tudo e mais alguma coisa deixa o vosso
amor neste vídeo faz isso muito ruim e
em sons lá fazer outro vídeo a seguir
porque hoje se calhar ainda afastou
depois de ter uma manhã e até a próxima